Brazilians idealized soccer, calling it "jogo bonito,"...
..."the beautiful game."
Pelé was its supreme artist.
So brilliant were his skills, so vibrant his smile.
He played at the 1958 World Cup and this global legend was born.
The teenager scored five goals, two of them in the final,...
...to lead Brazil to its first-ever world championship.
He never did say goodbye to his game or his fans.
Corporate endorsements carried him around the globe to promote soccer.
Pelé continued to touch those too young to have ever seen him play,...
...but knew the stories and images of the Brazilian...
...who captured the world's heart as a teenager...
...and spent a radiant lifetime starring in that affection.
We used to say, when is there gonna to be a new Pelé?
I say never.
Could he be better?
Could it be a different one?
But no more.